MIHAI LONESCU: Hello.
Welcome to Wallet
Developers Live.
We recently launched
Google Wallet Objects
and now we're creating a
series of short tutorials
to educate developers about
the Wallet Objects API.
The topic of today's
session is account creation.
And in particular,
we're going to talk
about creating two
accounts-- your OAuth account
and your Wallet
Objects issuer account.
Wallet Objects works with an
OAuth to service account model.
That means to grant access
to data in Wallet Objects,
you need to tell Wallet
Objects your OAuth
to service account
and then authorize
using the OAuth credentials.
And we'll go through
the steps of generating
those accounts and
the associated items
in them one by one.
First, let's create the
OAuth service account.
So to do that we'll go to the
new Google Cloud API console,
which is at
cloud.google.com/console.
And once we navigate
there, you'll
see a page which invites
you to create a new project.
So to do that, click
on Create Project.
And then let's select
the project name.
So in this case, let's
say my new account.
And you can use the
project ID as is
or select another
unique identifier.
Of course, agree to
the terms of service.
And then let's click Create.
I'll take a few seconds while
your project is being created.
And there we go.
Once your project
is created, we will
need to enable Wallet Objects.
So for that, go to
the APIs and Auth link
on the left navigation side.
And then in here, let's
search for Wallet Objects.
And then let's enable
the Wallet Objects API.
Now the API is enabled.
And all we have to do is
register our application.
For that, click on Register
Apps on the left side,
and then on the big red
Register App button.
You can select any name you
want for your application.
And leave the Web Application
radio button selected.
Then click Register.
Take a few seconds, and now
your new app is registered.
This will take us
to a screen where
it shows available
credentials below
to access various types of data.
In our case, we will
need to access data
on one of Google's servers.
So select the
Certificate section.
And in here click on the
Generate Certificate button.
This will create a new
certificate for you.
And now your
certificate is ready.
It's very important too download
the private key file somewhere
on your computer and
make a note of where
it is because we will need
this credential later on
to authenticate when we
access Google Servers.
So let's click on
Download Private Key.
And you can download
it anywhere.
You can name it-- it's a
pretty long name in here.
Just choose a shorter name
and save it somewhere.
So let's save this one.
And now we're done.
So two things that are
important to note here.
One is the email
address of your service
account, which is this one here.
And it's a big string at
developer.gserviceaccount.com.
So make a note of that
address and save it somewhere.
And of course, remember
where you generated
and saved your private key file.
You can always generate a new
key by clicking on the button.
And you can use
that key as well.
So in this case, we
keep the original one.
Now we switch to step two
of our configuration, which
is setting up your
Wallet Objects account.
The Wallet Objects
account is a dashboard
that allows you to manage your
Wallet Objects, your classes
and objects that you created.
We'll have more sessions
in the future highlighting
the functionality here.
For this session,
we'll just focus
on configuring and
setting up the account.
To access your Wallet
Objects account,
open your browser and go to
wallet.google.com/merchant/walletobjects.
So let's navigate there.
And you see for our
newly created account,
there is not much there.
To set it up, click on Account
Management on the left nav bar.
And here you have some
basic account information.
So make a note of the issuer ID.
This is your-- if you want
to call it-- merchant ID.
And it's very important
to make a note of it
and know what it is.
You will use it later
on when we make calls
to Google Wallet Objects.
One extra step you have to do
to properly set up the account
is to associate it with
your OAuth service account.
So let's share this account
with the OAuth service account.
So for that, we will
need to select and add
here the email address that we
created in the OAuth service
account.
So I'm switching back to
the OAuth service account,
and I'll copy
paste this address.
And then I'll go back here.
And I'm going to share it
with my Google Wallet Objects
account.
Now you're all done.
Your Wallet Objects
account is ready to be
used to issue REST
calls to Google Server.
So to recap, make a
note of your issuer ID.
Make a note of where you saved
your key file with the OAuth
credentials.
And also make a note of your
issuer account email address.
You can always go
to the Cloud Console
if you don't remember it to
copy paste it from there.
Or if you don't remember
where your keys are,
you can always
generate new keys.
And the issuer ID can be found
in your Google Wallet Objects
account.
And now that we have
our accounts configured
and all set up,
let's see what we
can do with all
that information.
I will show you how easy
it is to use your OAuth
credentials to make JSON calls.
In future session,
we will explore
how you can make more complex
calls using different languages
like Java, Python, PHP, Ruby.
But for now, we'll just do
a very simple call in JSON.
The first step
would be to generate
a bearer token as required
by the OAuth standard.
We have created a
set of tools for you
that makes that very easy.
To generate the bearer
token, have a look
at our testing section
in the documentation.
And in particular, we have
created a Java-based utility
that will allow you to
obtain a bearer token.
Our utility is
called tokenutil.jr.
And it's open sourced in GitHub.
We have a link from
our documentation.
And you can very
easily download it
by selecting the Row
download and save it
somewhere on your machine.
Once we have that
utility handy, then we
can go ahead and
request a bearer token.
Going back to our
documentation, use the command
I'm highlighting here to
obtain the bearer token.
Remember earlier we saved the
service account email address.
And I told you to
remember where you
saved your private key file.
So with that information, I'm
going to use this command here.
Copy paste it and
issue a command
to retrieve the bearer token.
So with some information
I already saved,
this is my test
service account email.
And I saved my credentials
in a file called key.p12.
So let's issue that command.
It takes a moment.
And we retrieve
back a bearer token.
So now you can copy paste
this guy here, and save it
somewhere in a notepad.
And we will use that to issue
a JSON command to the Wallet
Objects service.
Remember, this bearer token,
it's valid for an hour.
So if later on you want to play
again with issuing JSON calls,
remember to generate a new one.
How do we generate calls
to Google Wallet Objects?
So we have some examples
where we can very easily test
the REST API on
our testing page.
So if you page down a little bit
to the Test REST API section,
you will see a few
examples how you
can query for existing
objects or classes,
or how you can get a list of
classes, a list of objects,
how we can insert the class.
In future sessions, we'll go in
more detail over all of these.
For now, let's just show
you how you can easily
retrieve all these tough
classes for an account that
has already a few classes in it.
So the command is the
one highlighted here.
And very nicely you can use
call to issue the command.
So what do you need to
change in this template?
Of course, you have to
specify a class type.
And in this example,
we'll use a loyalty class.
You will need to change the
issuer ID with the issuer ID
we generated earlier.
So I'll switch again to your
Wallet Objects dashboard.
And remember, the issuer ID is
here under Account Management.
And finally, we will
use the bearer token
we just generated using the
utility tool we provided.
So if in this command we
override all this information
and copy paste it
somewhere in Notepad.
And I have an example here.
I'll just copy this, and
then go to a terminal.
And then we are now ready
to issue a command to Google
Wallet Objects to retrieve
a list of existing classes.
And here we are.
We received the JSON with
all the existing classes
in this Google Objects account.
So in future session,
of course, we'll
go in more detail
what everything means.
And you'll get a better
understanding of the response.
But for today, we
accomplished quite a lot.
We set up our OAuth account
and our Google Wallet Objects
account.
And with that information,
we obtained a bearer token,
and issued a JSON
call, and received
a list of existing loyalty
classes from our account.
And that concludes the first of
our Wallet Objects Tutorials.
In a future session, we'll
talk about templates, objects,
and classes.
Until then, goodbye.